c'est aujourd'hui l'anniversaire
d'antoine de saint-exupéry
l'écrivain et poète français est né le
29 juin 1901 lyon à l'occasion de son
125e anniversaire le château de la
bourdaisière à montlouis a décidé de
consacrer une exposition à son héros
fétiche le petit prince un parcours à
travers le parc de 55 hectares que nous
présente lucas chopin c'est aujourd'hui
sa journée mondiale 75 ans après sa
sortie en france le petit prince
d'antoine de saint-exupéry demeurent lé
ouvrages de littérature le plus vendu et
le plus traduit au monde après la bible
l'ouvragé vecteur de nombreux messages
humanistes mais il en est a en
particulier que les descendants de
l'auteur ont voulu mettre en avant à la
bourdaisière avant l'heure en fait des
préoccupations écologiques
l'homme doit respecter son vaisseau
parce que saint-exupéry décrit la terre
comme un vaisseau spatial nous sommes
tous équipages de ce vaisseau qui font
le l'espace et si nous détruisons notre
vaisseau bien et nous détruisons nous
mêmes ce qui est absurde
donc évidemment l'homme doit prendre
soin de la nature et de l'homme doit
respecter de la création ce message
était déjà là dans le petit prince parce
qu antoine de saint-exupéry qui voyait
le monde d'en haut qui voyait le monde
depuis son avion et qui avait rencontré
des gens partout dans le monde avait
compris l'importance de l'humain avait
compris l'importance de la planète qui
fait d'elle et déjà prendre soin de sa
planète saint-exupéry avait déjà compris
ça il l'a écrit très tôt bien avant tout
le monde
l'exposition anniversaire commence aux
abords du château de la bourdaisière à
montlouis sur loire
avant d'inviter le visiteur à s'enfoncer
dans les sous bois
certaines oeuvres déjà présente sur le
domaine ont été réinterprétés selon la
philosophie du petit prince et d'autres
comme ce bois de presque 100 m sont
directement tiré du livre pour le
propriétaire des lieux la dizaine
d'étapes de la visite tombait sous le
sens des messages délivrés par le petit
prince en relisant le petit prince je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait
regard dit posture qui pouvait devenir
10 expérience vise aventure pour les
familles l'écologie positive avec le
petit prince est probablement un des
aboutissements les plus remarquables de
ce qu'est la vie c'est à dire regardez
le vivant avec enthousiasme l'exposition
doit durer jusqu'au 15 novembre
mais il est prévu de la remettre en
place régulièrement pour les trois
années à venir